sind ihnen solche speziellen bilder
bestimmte szenen ganz besonders im kopf
geblieben in den letzten stunden tagen
das was hier anders waren was neuwahl
war einfach dass es zu dieser jahreszeit
so unerwartet kam dass die menschen
nicht stunden oder tage hatten sich
vorzubereiten
auch darüber wird man reden müssen haben
wir ausreichend vorsorge getroffen um
solche ereignisse rechtzeitig zu
erkennen
die diskussion läuft ja auch bereits das
muss geklärt werden nicht im sinne von
schuldzuweisungen sondern um auch in
anderen teilen von deutschland
rechtzeitig sicherstellen zu können dass
die gefährdung von menschen minimiert
wird
wir erleben heute dass in bayern und in
österreich und den anderen orten
ähnliche ereignisse sich abspielen und
das ist glaube ich ein wichtiger
ratschlag an warnsignal für uns alle
warum so viele tot haben sie für sich da
annähernd eine antwort gefunden ich
glaube es wäre falsch zu spekulieren
ohne konkrete antworten zu kennen
ich bin als wirtschaftsminister ganz
sicherlich nicht der spezialist im
katastrophenschutz und deshalb sage ich
wir müssen das sehr genau aufarbeiten um
für die zukunft auch lehren ziehen zu
können kann es überhaupt sein dass wenn
so viele menschen sterben bei einer
solchen katastrophe dass man dann sagen
kann die warnsysteme unser
katastrophenschutz die sind auf modernen
stand das hat alles funktioniert ich
glaube das haben wir nicht gesagt
sondern ich habe eben ganz deutlich
gesagt es muss sobald wir die
unmittelbare hilfe geleistet haben die
jetzt im vordergrund steht auch geschaut
werden gibt es dinge die nicht gut
gelaufen sind gibt es dinge die schief
gelaufen sind und das muss korrigiert
werden
es geht nicht um schuldzuweisungen es
geht um verbesserungen für die zukunft
und das müssen aber diejenigen machen
die nah an den ereignissen sind die auch
die erkenntnisse in der sache haben also
metereologe beispielsweise
katastrophenschutz einrichtungen die
müssen sich zusammensetzen ich habe
keinen zweifel dass das geschehen wird
wir haben einen großartigen
katastrophenschutz das thw für das ich
als staatssekretär einige jahre lang mit
zuständig war
hat einen grandiosen job gemacht die
feuerwehren ebenso wenn wir diese
freiwilligen organisationen nicht gehabt
hätten wäre die zahl der opfer und die
zahl der schäden wahrscheinlich sehr
viel größer geworden
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren